would you give me your full name a date
of birth please my name is hashim abedi
giving his name was the only truthful
thing terrorist hashem abadi told
investigators until now he'd always
blamed his older brother salman
who planted the bomb at the pop concert
and died in the attack
victims families at hashem's trial were
told he claimed he couldn't believe what
his brother had done
but in a prison interview weeks after
his sentence
hashem finally admitted he helped plan
the attack
the confession was revealed at the
public inquiry into the bombing
on the 22nd of october during the course
of that interview
hashem abedi admitted that he had played
a full part
and a knowing part in the planning and
preparation
for the arena attack yes i think that's
a that's a fair summary of that
so there is no doubt now
that your team's prosecution of him
and the crown prosecution service
prosecution of him was
entirely well-founded uh it was
and um and and there was no doubt in my
mind
22 people died and hundreds were injured
when the bomb exploded during the show
at manchester arena
in 2017
victim martin hett was 29 when he died
in the attack
his mother welcomed his killer's
confession but wished it had come
much earlier it's really disappointing
he didn't do that
at the trial i think it would have
helped
us as families quite a great deal
there's nothing i can do to change
you know his decision it was what he
chose to do
it's very regrettable that he did that
but
at the end of the day he's finally said
it and and
we need to hold on to that don't we
really hashem abadi was jailed for a
minimum of 55 years
so he'll be in his late 70s before he
can apply for parole
and freedom when or if that time
comes his confession now should help him
but his trial judge warned him he may
never
be released martin brunt sky news
manchester